this movie is a shared experience and
it's something that we see not just with
a big crowd but on a big screen so
everybody can feel immersed in it and
there's something that IMAX is able to
do to create the shared experience that
a regular theater isn't quite an
experience
Jurassic world IMAX screen was so
incredibly clear
it was amazing an ibex especially when
the t-rex roar he just built it like on
your chest it was overwhelming
exceedingly realistic I thought I was
actually in the movie I smelled t-rex
nose it was something IMAX 3d it's so
much better than this one
right yeah really great Bryce Dallas
Howard she is the best movie star I
since Betty Davis and on on IMAX her
eyes just glowed that last scene was
worth the entire Raptors and motorcycles
there's no other way to see it not just
once maybe twice three times this is
gonna be the first movie I've seen in 10
years or I'm going back again to see it
it's that full immersion that IMAX
creates that allows everybody to feel
like they're going on an adventure
together